sometimes
despite everything they still get
through
homegrown extremists who have made
terrorism
a fact of life
[Applause]
this is the story of the men and women
charged with stopping it
[Music]
we don't know their names we don't
really know what they're doing
but they are among us every minute of
every day
it's daybreak somewhere near birmingham
no sirens no fuss this is the part of
policing
we never see
open the door please
only the parents are in
an hour later the man they want strolls
home
they suspect he's a member of the band
far-right group
national action provisions you've been
arrested under on suspicion of being a
terrorist
which is it's not
absolutely not okay
is there a password or a pin code for
that phone
okay and obviously you've got some
phones in your bedroom are they ones
that you use as well
his possessions and phones are then
bagged up every message he has sent will
be read
it's the start of a legal process that
will determine
his innocence or guilt this officer is
going to take hold of your arm all right
there's now nothing unusual in far-right
extremism jobs for the west midlands
counter-terrorism unit
so this is your armory so this is the
army where weapons which have been
seized will be
stored securely
previous investigations have yielded an
extraordinary collection
this is just part of it this is a
a sample of weapons that have been
recovered over the past two years
from a variety of investigations within
the west midlands
so this is a homemade this is a homemade
mace
uh you know very heavy very dangerous
looks medieval and clearly based on on
some sort of old
types of weapons but in the wrong hands
would cause significant
harm and injury to anybody that was used
against loss of their mindset is around
preparing for a future
race war that may or may never come but
they want to be equipped to be able to
be
as armed as they can for that does it
ever surprise you what you find
in people's homes unfortunately not
anymore and this is
from another islamist investigation yes
this was from an investigation involving
a husband his wife and his sister
they were again plotting to carry out
attacks on uh people within the west
midlands
the sort of daesh al qaeda inspired
plots will still make up the majority of
our work probably about 80
of what we do continues to relate to
these threats to the west midlands
but the extreme right wings probably
makes up almost a fifth of what we do at
the moment so quite a significant
proportion
and continuing to grow is it the fastest
growing sector of your work
it is certain over the past two years
it's the one area where we have seen
more activity taking place nationally
more white people are now being arrested
for terrorism than those from
asian backgrounds
birmingham airport
13 million passengers a year and a team
of counter-terrorism suits
who never talk publicly about what they
do
until now it's just a fact that
terrorists live
work and travel in the same places we
all use
picking them out of a crowd is a 24 7
operation
so for example i would stop this car
eventually some glasses on it look
very walking very quickly he's very
coat on inside it just there would be
such an assumption that some of that
would be profiling for
people groups or whatever it is what's
the reality
that is an assumption what we sometimes
hear but equally we're dealing with
people from
um different backgrounds different
religions different ethnicities
it's a wide range of people we deal with
here at the airport ultimately we look
at
what the threat picture is here to the
uk and we use that to help us assist
in working out who we need to speak to
it's the conversations that follow
that are the most productive tactic
what is the the the political situation
in somalia at the moment is it something
there's a young man that you've
taken oh i don't even know you don't you
don't look at it at all
the parents don't uh talk to you about
it or anything no i got bigger problems
than that man
that young gentleman was traveling out
to prague for a few days
travelling alone from his passport a
club that was
actually born in mogadishu margaret
issue being the
city of in somalia which is a country of
interest to the british authorities
obviously problems are still ongoing
there with terrorist groups such as the
al-shabab
do you just get a sense sometimes that
something's wrong
uh yeah so somebody's behavior might be
wrong it might be their body language it
might be the
the way they talk to us in in that
they're nervous
and they might kind of contradict
themselves about
how long they're going for where they're
staying who they're staying with
etcetera
[Music]
flights in and out of the middle east
are of course of more interest to the
officers than a shuttle service to
aberdeen
but the rise in activity among far-right
extremists means that sometimes
flights to eastern and central europe
are just as closely watched
nearly everyone who works at birmingham
airport whether they're serving coffee
or signing out hire cars is trained in
spotting the signs
we're constantly looking out really for
anything
that's suspicious you do it every day
really without knowing really but at the
same time
keeping that balance between looking out
for it as well as keeping it safe and
happy environment for
so okay if i run the dog only places
thank you and then
there's spencer certainly as we've
walked through the airport before
people will try and avoid the dog that
will obviously start alarm bells ringing
for us and we need to obviously check
out those people further so what do they
do
in general you'll find that people will
rush to the toilets to avoid the dog
or certainly move quickly as possible
away from the dog
it then falls to this man's team to step
in he oversees
counter-terrorism at birmingham airport
for me criminals are criminal crimes are
crying
but there's obviously a sliding scale of
that and terrorism sits very much
towards the top end of that scale of
course
you're talking to your family away from
work about
how you and your colleagues protect us
all what do you tell them
when i talk to my family it would be the
same we'll talk about to any other
member of the public it's just about
being aware raise awareness be vigilant
and don't be afraid to if there is any
doubt there is no doubt this is
a threat that's been around for a long
time
but by no means should you impact upon
your day-to-day living
[Applause]
they now know that some terrorists have
actively avoided this airport
because they're wary they'll be stopped
we
want to make birmingham airport as hard
a target as possible for
anyone who wants to come here
for the purpose other than traveling
or collecting somebody of course it
doesn't always work
at the end of last year mi5 conceded
that
chances had been missed to stop salman
abadi
the manchester arena bomber the parsons
green bomber ahmed hassan
wasn't monitored properly and there are
many other suspects who are arrested
their lives turned upside down and
they're never charged
i think we still make mistakes i i think
we still get many things wrong
but we're open enough to admit when we
made mistakes
and we learned from them uh the attacks
in 2017
were tragedies which affected many
families across the country
how does that feel when attacks get
through uh
it means we need to work harder next
time it needs me to we need to do more
next time
let's go up to birmingham now let's go
to becky johnson who's in birmingham
the police have sealed off an area of
birmingham there have been searches at
two further addresses including a tower
block not far from here
there is something of an inescapable
truth in our second city
it's seen one of the highest numbers of
arrests charges and raids
anywhere in europe i've lived and worked
in birmingham for for almost 25 years
i wouldn't want to live or work anywhere
else i think it's a fantastic city
and i think the work we can do is
countertops and policing will help to
keep it that way
but it has a very highly significant
proportion of
islamist and now far-right activity
hasn't it
i think we've seen individuals and
groups sort of developing within
birmingham
i've also said we've also seen lots of
information intelligence coming from our
communities
you know we we i think we get some of
the most
highest level support from many
communities within the country here here
in birmingham and i'm really proud of
that
everyone knows the pressure on police
budgets particularly
is counter terrorism immune from that
does it affect you and the work that you
can do
i think anything that professional
neighbor police think is going to to
impede our ability to keep communities
safe from terrorism
it's fine they need the support of all
kinds of colleagues
the security services the government and
us
the public we're now arguably an
angrier and more unstable country
inside counter-terrorism complacency
is never an option
you